[Musique]
nouvel épisode de F star avec un
prospect dont on va parler qui est assz
attendu depuis un petit moment
maintenant pour se faire je suis encore
avec les inarables HUG et Julien on ne
se quitte plus je vous vois plus que ma
famille c'est incroyable salut les gars
comment ça va salut salut pierre ça fait
plaisir TR VO la M que de l'amour que de
l'amour et puis si vous avez pas écouté
l'underdogs je vous représente au nom de
toute l'équipe envergure nos vœux les
meilleurs pour l'année 2024 évidemment
donc aujourd'hui on va aller direction
USC encore une fois j'ai envie de dire
parce qu'on a parlé d'un prospect Joshua
Morgan un peu sombre la fois dernière
dans underdos qui était déjà dans cette
équipe de USC HUG qui est-il ce freshman
pour une fois a Isaia col vous savez moi
je suis un peu heureux et un peu ému
parce que ça veut dire que c'est la
dernière fois de l'année qu'on va parler
de USC en tout cas moi et et ça me fait
du
bien euh et puis en plus c'est la fin de
la pack 12 donc un peu un peu d'émotion
quand même devant cet épisode j'aurais
plus à supporter à supporter ce coach
exécrable mais c'est pas le sujet du
jour isaiïah colier quel homme aza
coliar c'est un joueur qui était top 3
recru
lycéen l'an dernier d'après ESPN d'après
rivals après tout ce que vous voulez
c'est un garçon qui est né en Georgie et
Georgia comme dirait le chanteur Georgia
c'est une magnifique interprétation et
donc de parents pas du tout sportifs
pour le coup un tonton qui lui est coach
de basket au lycée et donc il a joué
pour son tonton euh au lycée et il a été
joueur de l'année il a participé au
McDonald all améicans et cetera et
cetera il est arrivé du coup comme
recrue 5 étoiles hyper côté par tout le
monde et il a décidé de choisir USC pour
les choix académiques hein il est parti
de l'autre côté du du pays pour des
raisons académique et pour une relation
avec le coach euh en même temps tu
choisis pas USC pour le basket on le
sait très bien euh et il finit dans une
équipe on va en parler avec énormément
de de fils de pour le coup et je vous
propose quand même pour mes chers
auditeurs hein euh pour euh pour nos nos
amoureux des calembourg de faire un 94
pied avec HUG de Hal où je vais vous
donner trois anecdotes sur isïa colère
et il va y en avoir une seule euh qui
sera vrai
euh la première anecdote sur ce
joueur-là c'est que ça dans préféré en
soirée c'est le collier serré c'est un
chaud lapin la deuxème anecdote oui bah
vous pouvez vous retenir de rire mais je
vois ce r un peu gêné je l'entends tu
vois il a pas osé bah si bah si j'ai osé
et ce qui est bien avec Az colè c'est la
deuxème anecdote c'est peut-être le
joueur le plus franc qu' vous pouvez
retrouver bah oui il l'a forcément on
dire qu'il est fr du collier évidemment
et puis la trè e qui est évidemment
évidemment fausse euh c'est quelque
chose de tragique voilà je je fais du
assasseur émotionnel c'est un joueur qui
a a vécu un gros deuil de son cousin et
de son meilleur ami qui est le fils du
coup de de son oncle qui était coach de
basket et donc il porte ça avec lui et
c'est un mec on voit qui est très proche
de sa famille et euh qui euh qui
commence qui a commencé l'année avec
vraiment une une mauvaise nouvelle et
qui a réussi à encaisser parce qu'ils
sont partis en tournée en tournée
européenne et donc voilà c'est un joueur
qui a l'air vraiment très très proche de
de sa famille
et et qui est pas dans l'exubérance donc
un un bon garçon je pense aussi d' après
les
interview on va laisser les auditeurs
comme la dernière fois on donne pas la
réponse on suppose qu'elle est assez
évidente HUG on part sur ça ouais moi je
pense que le collier est serré là tout
le monde tout le monde a dit
bah ouais moi je le vois bien découper
tu vois bouger c'estes gros son gros
popotin là en soirée tu vois bien musclé
sur un sur un petit air calienté pour
moi ça me semble évident est-ce que tu
peux nous faire une présentation
physique du joueur un petit peu quel
joueur est-il quoi il ressemble alors le
truc c'est avec AIA colier c'est que
c'est difficile d'avoir la vérité euh
sur le sur les chiffres c'est un c'est
un joueur il fait l'effet yoyo euh il
fait peut-être pas le programme comme
j'aime mais il fait l' fait yoyo euh
parfois annoncé à 1,90 parfois annoncé à
1,96 parfois listé à 88 kg parfois listé
à 100 kg une envergure qui varierait un
minimum he une petite fourchette entre 1
M93 et 2 M10 euh il y a quoi entre les
deux à part mon corps en entier on sait
pas donc compliqué de d'avoir les
mesures nous visuellement on se
dirigerait quand même sur un joueur
plutôt proche des 6 pieds 3 4 j'ai pas
l'impression qu'on est sur un mec si
grand que ça et avec des bras pas si
longs alors le poids oui pas de souci
moi comme disent qu'il fait pas loin de
100 kg je je veux bien le croire que du
muscle mais voilà on se disait juste
avant de commencer qu'on qu'on croyait
pas là dans ces bras de 2 M11 et dans
des mains gigantesques on va attendre
les mesures officielles forcément au
combine pour être fixé mais mais voilà
on va se dire 1,93 euh on va se dire à
peu près 95 kg et on va se dire une
envergure par
tailleepo Julien on va passer avec toi
pour que tu nous parles un petit peu du
du contexte collectif dans lequel il
évolue cette année à USI avec comme l'a
dit HUG et rappelé fort justement
beaucoup de fils d' et pas forcément
gage de de résultat en tout cas à
l'instanté on va aussi rappeler qu'il
est blessé actuellement pendant un mois
je crois ouais c'est ça Mo au plus donc
c'est on Los Angeles la fac de
California donc en PCT pour cette
dernière année la dernière la dernière
année de cette conférence à peu près
droite quoi le C Andy Enfield vous avez
entendu quelques mots de HUG qui
apparemment le porte dans son cœur ouais
c'est un vrai un vrai tacticien
exceptionnel person all of Fame et donc
l'équipe est composée c'est vrai de du
fils de de l Bron pas n'importe qui donc
bronny James et du fils de Denis RMAN je
l' cette fois-ci je l'ai pas oublié les
gars qui arrive de Washington State qui
a 4 hein qui ressemble un peu lui au
moins on peut dire qu'il a des presque
les mensuration son pè au niveau de la
taille et du poids j'espère qu'il fait
pas les mêmes soir c'est tout
franchement il a les il a les mêmes
ongles en fait il se il se plein les
ongles d'un petit peu foufou aussi
euh voilà c'est une équipe qui est qui
est qui penche surtout à l'extérieur
avec des de fortes personnalités donc
isaacer on parlera sûrement de sa
personnalité plus tard il y a euh notre
ami Boogie euh qui qui tient beaucoup la
gonfle qui a une grosse comment dire qui
participe beaucoup au jeu qui prend
beaucoup de shoot il y a Kobe Johnson
peut-être que tu tu l'oublies peut-être
dans ta liste de joueurs pour la draft
HUG
ouais mais je l'aime beaucoup Kobe
Johnson mais ce sera peut-être un
underdgs et je laisserai je laisserai
mon tour moi je je me focuse sur le
grand frère jellen qui est un jour
incroyable loterie ici mais t'es pas
trompé
d'accord pas mal et puis euh voilà et le
le reste de l'ffectif donc Rodman qui a
pas mal de shoot quand même et qui a
plutôt un quatre et ensuite il y a une
comment
dire quatre joueurs intérieurs qui
tournent avec une hiérarchie qui est pas
forcément très claire on a parlé de
Morgan dans un under dog il y a trois
autres joueurs dont un
ilchukou qui a un joueur 5 étoiles qui
arrivé l'année dernière mais qui a eu
une grosse alerte de sonanté et on peut
dire qu'il y a du mal à revenir quoi
voilà et euh et euh on parlera peut-être
de hornery parce que il faut parler du
spacing de cette équipe on en a parlé en
off alors c'est c'est un des comment
dire un des des problèmes de l'équipe
qui qui peut-être pèse sur le contexte
dans lequel on on le voit on voit
évoluercire euh donc il y a quand même
Booky cullins qui a un shooterter à 40 6
% c'est ça à 3 points je crois qui est
dans les 20 premiers shooters de la NC à
3 points donc c'est c'est un gros
shooterur et puis autour pas gros monde
qui est capable de d'écarter le jeu et
puis euh colier joue aussi avec des des
intérieurs qui sont pas forcément euh
moi je dirais quand même à part Morgane
même si vous n'êtes pas d'accord qui
sont pas forcément des des foudres de
guerre en pour finir les pick and roll
et encore moins pour finir en pick and
pop donc ça
ça rend le jeu de
alors pas forcément agréable à regarder
en attaque et un peu compliqué pour
colir on va en parler plus tard je
pense bah juste pour compléter tu vois
si on est dans la comparaison parce
qu'on c'est une comparaison qui va y
avoir toute l'année en filé sur le le
meilleur porteur de balle le meilleur
poste 1 entre guillemets initiateur il y
a lui à topic en gros qui se tirait la
bour et là où Nicolas topic a un un
spacing et un fond de jeu qui est
vraiment fait pour lui où il tient tout
le temps le ballon et qui a un vrai
possibilité d'écarter le jeu et d'aller
au panier à Zay coliè c'est quand même
beaucoup plus compliqué donc le le
contexte est clairement en avantage de
Topit et très défavorable à colilière
par contre c'est intéressant pour on en
discutera plus tard effectivement pour
la projection NBA pour voir ce que le
joueur peut donner loin du ballance ce
qui risque quand même d'arriver vu les
équipes qui vont drafter dans le top 10
cette saison h et du coup on peut
regretter que que James été out autant
de temps parce que ça aurait été
intéressant de le voir jouer avec un un
autre enfin un porteur de
balle créateur quoi enfin qui qui s'est
lâché la balle et qui
s'est comment dire créé du jeu parce que
il en est un peu privé quo messieurs
vous nous avez parlé du contexte
collectif maintenant j'aimerais savoir
sur le terrain qu'est-ce que ça donne à
za colier balle en main quels sont ses
points forts qu'est-ce qui est vendeur
pour SC qu'est-ce qu'on qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce qu'on voit directement quand
on regarde jouer aza au jeu qu'on
appelle basketball et ben on va
peut-être pas aller sur le point le plus
évident qu'on regarde le joueur mais
c'est la passe c'est Isa coler c'est un
excellent passeur les les chiffres sont
pas forcément au rendez-vous avec pas
mal de de pert de balles mais en terme
de créativité on aime beaucoup ce que le
J peut proposer on voit un vrai
initiateur de jeu capable de de passer
ément en mouvement capable de passer sur
drive and kick capable de sortir le
ballon avec enfin des passes à une main
des deux côtés alors effectivement il y
a une préférence motrice sur la main
droite pour la passe même s'il préfère
dever par la gauche on va reparler
euh évidemment le joueur s'est passé
avec des passes directes des passes LEB
des passes au sol ça pas de problème et
surtout ce qu'on aime c'est la
créativité de la passe des angles
parfois parfois compliqués des petits
intervalles et et puis il passe dans le
mouvement euh pour moi ça c'est la
marque des des forts passeurs au niveau
collégial et ensuite au niveau NBA c'est
que il te pas il fait pas la passe là où
le joueur est actuellement ù le
shooterter est actuellement où le Grand
qui roule est actuellement mais là où le
joueur doit être pour marquer
efficacement c'est un joueur qui
vraiment lie bien le mouvement les
trajectoires et puis il y a de la
manipulation visuelle alors la fameuse
Nol pass mais il est capable de de
casser la défense en regardant d'un côté
et puis en envoyant la balle de l'autre
côté donc vraiment des une qualité
complète dans ce jeu-là qui va lui
permettre euh au niveau supérieur
d'exister de faire briller les autres
sachant queil y aura des des pont compa
à l'intérieur la le point d'amélioration
sur ce point fort ça va être les pertes
de balles mais c'est plus quelque chose
qui va être lié à son à son drible on en
rediscutera un petit peu plus tard ouais
pour parler de ça par rapport au aux
pertes de balles et et sont il y a il y
a quand même quelque chose qu'on regarde
souvent c'est le pourcentage assist
turnover il est juste de 1,1 pour lui
donc qui peut être un petit peu
inquiétant sur le papier ouais beaucoup
de beaucoup de pertes de balles vraiment
plus lui quand il a la balle plutôt que
quand il fait la passe je trouve et à
côté de ça aussi des des intérieurs avec
pas mal de mains carré quoi euh tu vois
il y a les les grands qui sur le le rôle
perdent le ballon euh ou bien des des
mecs qui doivent normalement faire
sortir d'un écran pour tirer puis
finalement il stagne et donc la balle
finit dans le gradin et c'est plus la
faute du du receveur que de la faute du
du quarterback euh enfin dans la dans le
parallèle dans le parallèle mais je je
suis pas si inqu que ça par ce ratio
assist turnover pour la passe peut-être
plus dans le Drive et Julien toi
qu'est-ce qui te séduit le plus chez
Azay cololier mais dans dans ce qu'on
voit euh euh cette année euh à USC euh
puisqueen fait c'est la passe en son
gros point fort c'est clair euh moi
j'aime bien quand même la le le le
comment dire le chos permanent qu'il est
capable de créer en drivant euh
c'est-à-dire le le fait qu'il est tout
le temps euh il est tout le temps prêt à
foncer dans le tas à c'est ce qu'on
moins qu'on puisse dire et à à créer du
danger en avec la balle en balle en main
et euh en voulant aller au cercle et du
coup voilà en pouvant dé il va varier il
va livr dépasse enfin
vari en tout cas les la la défense
craint ses driv et craint ses
pénétrations on va dire comme ça et ça
il sa en jouer et il aime beaucoup ça il
on fait beaucoup que ce soit en
transition sur jeu placé et ce que je
trouve intéressant c'est qu'il arrive à
justement à à à mettre la pression comme
ça sur la défense de sur plusieurs
positions sur le terrain il est capable
de commencer en postup et euh pouvoir
soit enfoncer son joueur et faire la
passe scorer soit partir dans en
transition ce qu'il aime beaucoup faire
après un rebond ce qu' un petit peu le
l'ADN on peut dire de l'équipe euh où
ils ont l'attaque est moche mais la
défense ils font beaucoup d'effort et ça
part vite après le rebond défensif euh
soit avec un jeu en screen et et partir
au partir au drive quoi et puis
l'avantage vu son jeu c'est que comme
les États-Unis c'est pas le pays où tu
as les meilleurs mutuels tu as un peu
peur de défendre quoi parce qu'à tout
moment tu une mâchoire ou une épaule
donc il va avoir plus en France tu vois
je pense qu'il tournerait à peine 10
points parce qu'on a la sécurité sociale
là les ridens ils réfléchissent à deux
fois avant de avant d'aller dessus donc
c'est un jour qui va pouvoir créer
énormément de fautes et et de points
faciles moi aussi comme point vraiment
enfin qui saute même aux yeux et tu en a
un petit peu parler HUG c'est son
physique il a quand même un physique qui
est presque plus proche du footbolleur
américain tu tu as fait le parallèle
tout à l'heure mais c'est c'est vraiment
ça et en plus de ça ce qui est un peu
peu terrifiant entre guillemets c'est
qu'on a l'impression qu'il peut encore
ajouter du muscle par rapport à ça et le
rendre encore plus puissant il dégage
une grande puissance aussi quand quand
il drive justement parce qu' il arrive
avec toute cette ce physique naturel
qu'il
a à dégager ça et en ça déjà moi je
trouve déjà pour moi c'est même le
premier truc que quand on le voit jouer
au basket qui qui me saute aux yeux en
fait alors je sais pas si vous vous êtes
OK avec ça après ça veut pas dire que il
est il a des qualités athlétiques
exceptionnelles et d'ailleurs on peut
modérer tout de suite le propos par
rapport à ça dire avoir une grande
puissance c'est pas forcément signe de
de verticalité non plus messieur
tout à fait après le le corps il il a
travaillé le dit en interview c'est un
truc il a dans son état où il a il a
joué au basket en High School c'est un
truc il fallait être physique donc il a
travaillé son physique c'est pas quelque
chose de naturel c'est quelque chose
qu'il a bossé et donc on peut peut
penser qu'il va continuer à développer
comme tu as dit Pierre et par rapport à
la verticalité c'est vrai que c'est
assez frustrant c'est pas frustrant
c'est que voilà c'est un gars qui va qui
qui va pas très très haut audessus du
cercle il est capable d'aller dun en
contre-attaque mais c'est un c'est une
de ces caractéristiques qui va pas finir
très très haut au Cercle quand il va au
drive d'ailleurs une St par rapport à ça
un seul un seul dunk en 16 match ouais
ouais bah on voit même des transitions o
il est un contre zéro les commentateurs
disent what chot watch shot et il fait
un vieux layup main droite alors
euh on pourrait se dire vu le vu le
corps que il peut mettre des gros
marteaux mais c'est pas c'est pas
forcément le cas il a suivi les
enseignements de Rocky 6 tu vois quand
tu es plus plus rapide SVE St Stallone
tu vois quand tu es plus plus rapide bah
tu es le plus puissant et euh alors
l'avantage c'est que ça permet de jouer
longtemps et ce que dit Ju sur le
développement du corps je trouve ça
assez intéressant et intelligent c'est
que le garçon il a très vite compris
avec son tonton qui le coachait que ben
il irait pas le plus vite il irait pas
le plus haut par contre il a un
morphotype qui va lui permettre de faire
le plus mal et on voit qu'il y a
beaucoup de joueurs en en NBA ça leur
permet d'être prêt plus rapidement et
d'être efficace rapidement on en a vu
beaucoup ces dernières années des
scoreurs puissants qui qui pouvaient
jouer on est sur un type différent
joueur différent et c'est un joueur que
j'aime bien mais cam Thomas qui était
pas un énorme athlète dans la dans le
premier n pas qui était par énorme
athlète verticale il est arrivé il
faisait bouger tout le monde près du
panier en mettant de l'impact en
encaissant le contact en finissant et on
a vu que très vite ça peouit être un
scoreur donc ça c'est plutôt bon signe
pour lui
ouais il a un jeu bouli quoi on peut le
dire euh c'est un de ses moves en tout
cas ce qu'on voit depuis le début de
l'année c'est qu'il aime bien arriver en
drive mettre un coup d'épaule qui s'est
géré quoi pour faire de la place et pour
finir près du cercle le le premier match
il est vraiment si vous voulez savoir
qui Isa colar vous regardez son premier
match de l'année face à K state il joue
25 minutes il met 18 points 7 sur 9 au
tir c'est quasiment du layup où il
rentre dans les défenseurs il les
défonce tous et il finit fort près du
panier il fait six passes décisives six
pertes de balles sur quasiment C CIN
fautes quasiment C fautes offensive donc
il fald sur son premier match et
quasiment que de la faute offensive et
vous pouvez voir ses points forts quand
il est défendu par des arrières où il
les boul où il le rentre dedans où il
les poste où vraiment il est inarrêtable
et vous pouvez voir c'est l'imitation en
deè mi-temps où il est défendu par par
des ailiers notamment Arthur kaluma qui
est un excellent défenseur et lié depuis
plusieurs années et là où c'est plus
compliqué pour lui c'est je trouve un
excellent match le tout premier match de
saison pour voir pour scoter Isa colier
B justement la perche est tout trouvée
HUG tu va parler de ces limitations en
tout cas à l'heure actuelle quelles
sont-elles selon toi pareil sa plus
grosse limitation dans son jeu je vais
prendre une limitation qui va être relou
pour son point fort parce que c'est un
joueur on se disait avant de lancer que
trouver une un point d'entrée en NBA un
truc élite c'est compliqué parce que son
plus gros point fait peut-être c'est de
n'avoir aucun énorme point fort et
notamment sur le drive parce que c'est
un joueur on le voit et on le comprend
très vite qui va être très porté sur le
la création balle en main euh qui peut
accélérer il est très bon pour changer
son rythme en accélérant il est bon pour
changer de direction sur son drive euh
main droite main gauche j'entends par
contre le mec une fois qu'il est lancé
il s'est pas décélérer il a ce problème
de freinage qui va lui permettre à terme
s'il le met dans son jeu Ben de mieux
lire le la défense d'arrêter de faire
quatre passages en force en de provoquer
quatre passages en force en rentrant
dans les dans le porteur de balle et
puis ça lui permettra de s'arrêter de
pouvoir créer plus d'écart sur peut-être
du pullup midistance ou un flotteur un
Runner des choses qu'il a pas du tout en
magasin donc pour moi ce ce freinage
c'est vraiment le le point à débloquer
pour passer du porteur de balle moyen
voir peutêtre négatif au vrais porteur
de balle créateur de jeu NBA c'est un
point en comparaison qu'on reprochait à
jadan iy qui était un meilleur athlète
un vertical mais on se disait ah jadan
iy il a pas qu'une vitesse mais il s'est
pas décéléré et on le voit en NBA
aujourd'hui jadan iy ne sait pas encore
ralentir son jeu et donc il manque
cruellement d'efficacité et on peut
craindre la même chose pour pour aayia
colier Julien tu as le même défaut
numéro 1 ou tu en vois un autre
ouais je vais en prendre un autre parce
qu'il y en a un autre qui est évident
c'est le shoot ouais le shot extérieur
qui est pas du tout qui est pas en place
en fait il est pas pas du tout en place
il est pas en place alors il y a des euh
il y a du mieux il tourne il tourne à
alors il tourne à 31 % c'est ça je à TR
points ouais surt très peu de tentative
finalement parce que je ouais il prend
trois tirs par match c'est ça he h ouais
ouais il est à 48 sur c'est un volume de
48 shoots sur sur ce qu'il a fait depuis
le début euh et euh bon on voit la
trajectoire est plate parfois ça manque
de pop alors il y a il est plutôt c'est
plutôt en C SH de toute façon en ce
moment il on voit pas ni très très peu
prendre des des pullup à TR et puis
quand on le voit shooter en poulop à de
c'est c'est très très compliqué quoi on
sent que c'est pas trop son truc à part
que il y a une position qu'il a
acctionne je trouve tiit en tête de
raquette tu vois sur la gauche là on
sent qu'il a il a travaillé son enfin
que ça passe ici et il il enuse un peu
parce que c'est là où il rentre le plus
facilement il a pas un shot naturel il
le sait il en parle dans les interviews
c'est quelque chose don il parle très
facilement c'est un de ces points
faibles il bosse beaucoup alors manu a
l'habitude de dire que c'est le truc le
moins difficile à travailler donc on
peut penser que ce point faible qu'il a
ça peut s'améliorer voilà h et après 66
% au lanc franc si on prend ça comme
indicateur c'est pas c'est pas énorme
ouais pour un joueur qui shoot pardon
juste je finis excuse-moi pierre après
je mais c'est un joueur qui prend des
qui prend pas mal de de shoot ilate
assez élevé qu ou éevé c'est c'est ce
que j'allais te te dire par rapport au
justement c'est ça je voulais parler des
des des des lancer franc c'est vrai que
il est je crois quasiment 5 lancer franc
tentés par match que 66 % qui est
presque un finalement un pourcentage
d'intérieur moyen c'est vrai que ça ce
côtélà peut faire peur aussi et dans sa
technique de tir c'est V que le tir est
très très peu fluide c'est un espèce de
petit tir vers l'avant comme tu comme tu
le dis qui a une trajectoire assez plate
qui pas très joli à voir d'ailleurs
c'est vrai qu'on sent qu'il y a quand
même un gros gros travail à faire
surtout dans une ligne qui est très
orientée quand même la NBA sur les les
les les tirs à trois points enfin plus
qu'elle n'a jamais été en fait donc euh
ça en pour moi c'est peut-être le truc
le plus marquant par rapport à à l'air
de dans la NBA dans dans laquelle on est
peut-être
et ça pose ça pose un problème très
rapidement c'est que Isaiah coler s'il a
pas le ballon en main quel est son rôle
puisquon on l'a dit c'est pas un shoot
comment dire c'est pas un shoot fiable
pour le moment on n pas encore parlé de
la défense mais on va peut-être en évoqu
par le toucher de mot c'est pas du tout
un stoppeur on sait pas on sait pas si
c'est par manque d'envie ou par
limitation on va voir c'est pas un
joueur qui a les capacités athlétiques
d'être fort dans du cut non plus ça va
pas être un mec que tu vas faire cut
back d'or ou de choses comme ça pour
terminer euh et on le voit cette année à
USC quand Boogie elice a le ballon dans
la main bah lui il se cache un petit peu
et il est pas très utile donc on a un
vrai problème d'usage d'asaya coler si
tu lui donnes pas le ballon tout de
suite et on pense qu'il est pas
forcément prêt pour l'avoir et
d'ailleurs les défenses pour finir sur
le tir le l'ont très très vite scouté au
bout de un match euh jeis les pick and
roll les gens ils passent dessous euh
donc les peu de tir en pouup qui prend à
trois points c'est parce que le
défenseur il est 10 pied en dessous ou
bien parce que le défenseur a switché et
on l'a déjà vu en galère sur des ailiers
euh aussi dans dans du switch donc on a
on a un vrai on a des vrais défauts très
évidents très vite mis en en place et
que la NBA va aussi va aussi abuser dès
sa première année et bah justement HUG
tu on c'est un sujet dont on n pas parlé
du tout c'est sa défense que ce soit
soit sur porteur de balle pardon ou non
porteur de balle comment il se
débrouille dans ce secteur là alors on a
vite compris que c'était pas un stoppeur
défensif pour autant est-ce que il y a
moyen qu'il ne soit pas négatif assez
vite je trouve qu'il bouge pas si mal
que ça
euh j'ai pas de j'ai pas tant de
problème de de latéralité j'ai alors
peut-être que les les appuis sont un peu
plus lourds parce qu'il y a une masse à
à déplacer mais je je je pense qu' aussi
qu'il y a assez peu d'investissement
puisqu'il a toujours été une star
offensive par les les années au
précédents et au lycée aussi on en a vu
beaucoup un des mecs comme ça une s et
quand il s'y met il y a une maturité
physique une puissance qui lui permet
d'encaisser du contact et d'être relou
euh sur des petits et sur des ailiers
c'est un mec qui peut switcher sur des
postes 2 TR euh sans aucune difficulté
quand il s'y met euh par contre il peut
se faire prendre dans les pit and roll
et il va pas faire l'effort pour revenir
dessus et loin du ballon euh c'est un
joueur qui va être assez focus sur la
balle donc il peut se faire surprendre
et il va jouer la carotte sur les lignes
de passe mais il manque de concentration
donc pour moi on n pas du tout sur un
défenseur abouti mais on n'est pas
forcément sur un un projet un projet
clos je pense que c'est un joueur qui
peut qui peut en arrivver au niveau
supérieur essayer de gratter des minutes
comme ça parce que il va devoir donner
des arguments à son coach pour le faire
jouer HUG on est pareil on n'est pas sur
un défenseur morné come on dit Julien
pardon excuse-moi mais en fait moi moi
il y a deux trucs que je vois c'est que
même quand il est motivé moi je l'ai
trouvé parfois je trouvé un peu juste en
défense quoi euh au niveau du de la
défense individuelle j'ai j'ai trouvé
qu'il se faisait qu' pouvait se faire
passer euh après c'est c'est un c'est un
gars par contre comme HUG dit qui aime
le ballon et qui est il est fort en
style quand même il fait beaucoup de il
s'est volé le ballon il s'est anticiper
à certaines trajectoires euh voilà c'est
un truc ça qui sait faire il a des bons
chiffres là-dedans et ça se voit dans
les matchs quoi il y a toujours un
moment où il va il va voler deux trois
ballons de suite parce qu'il sont le
truc et voilà après est-ce que ça VO oui
on a en fait moi quand on en parle comme
ça je ça me fait penser à à Maturin on
disait que c'était un potentiellement
c'était un bon défenseur et que il le
montrait pas mais il a pas les mêmes
atout quoi Maturin c'était
à il était il avait déjà une envergure
on Savit qu'il avait une grande
envergure il avait et puis euh
physiquement il était il était au-dessus
il était plus grand
ouais je sais je sais pas trop quoi dire
de cette défense comme comme a dit c'est
pas on a on le voit pas assez faire pour
pour conclure ouais c'est pareil pas ce
côté investissement que comme le le
finifit HUG qui a rarement le cas chez
les jeunes starifiés en NC en fait c'est
vra c'est très rare que les stars
offensives NC soit de très grands
défenseurs et quelque fois on a des
bonnes surprises à l'étage supérieur
d'autant que moi je suis assez d'accord
avec HUG c'està dire que son physique
est quand même un avantage il y a quand
même des joueurs même sur des posts de
garde qui ont des physiques imposants et
qui arrivent à en tirer parti l'exemple
le plus parlant peut-être alors ce sera
jamais le cas ce sera pas le même voir
on est d'accord mais il y a dans son
physique un petit côté Marcus sm aussi
Messieurs alors c'est c'est un prof
c'est un projet qui a annoncé très
haut notre ami colliè est-ce qu'on y
croit c'est c'est un projet qui qui est
sur la la pente descendante il était
annoncé top 3 de draft en début d'année
voir premier choix et plus ça va et plus
et plus ça tombe alors là la blessure ça
va pas aider et le contact collectif va
pas aider euh mais mais c'est en train
un peu de chuter je trouve que ça chute
même un peu trop il y a il y a une
décote qui est faite
euh il y a assez peu de créateurs balle
en main et il y a assez peu de de
passeurs aussi bon que lui donc dans
cette cuvée là si on prend vraiment le
côté je veux de la création on on va
vite le retrouver il y a un physique qui
permet de d'avoir comment dire une une
projection et un calibre NBA et de
l'impact rapidement il y a on l'a dit de
de la passe il y a de la potentialité il
y a un garçon qui a l' d'être en place
mentalement il y a un entourage familial
qui a l'air d'être très très sain donc
je je je vais le rester sur le projet
dans du Lot tripque le problème je pense
pour lui euh c'est que la CU est assez
faible donc beaucoup d'équipes vont
aller peut-être plus au fit qu'au talent
cette année je peux me tromper là-dessus
je suis pas dans les dans les front
office mais ça peut et d'aut enfin le
deuxième truc c'est que les équipes qui
vont drafter top 10 comme ça enfin top
10 elles ont déjà toutes quasiment leur
leur fort créateur balle en main et et
ça c'est pas c'est pas ouf pour lui à
part peut-être Washington
et sonan Antonio et à ce moment-là
faudra passer devant à niikola topic
moi j'ai une question par rapport à ça
par rapport justement à cette QV vu que
tu me tends un peu la perche encore une
fois est-ce que c'est le meilleur
prospect américain au poste de garde
col en gros il y a la question peut-être
voilà c'est ça que je dire il peuvent
passer
devant en fa diff
tu sais que tu peux
est-ce que je peux dire ça tu sais que
tu peux pas en faire des des tu tu
mettrais Dinga mais jeis pas dans
titulaire sa pas moi je sa pas tu peux
avoir titulaire mais l'avantage de ces
garçons là c'est qu'en fait ils peuvent
jouer loin du ballon et ils peuvent tout
de suite mettre du tir extérieur et donc
bah si tu tombes à Detroit bon ça
arrivera pas parce qu'on est sur du top
TR pic mais faisons vite fait la liste
comme ça tu tombe à Detroit tuqu que une
GAM donc tu peux jouer à côté et il joue
ilier ornest à laaméo donc tu peux avoir
un rôle Terry Rosière et jouer à côté
Raptors tuas Scoty barns euh si tu es
blazer tu as SCOT andenderson Memphis
tuas j moment et tout donc c'est ces
joueurs là ont l'avantage de pouvoir
être des joueurs de catch and shoot là
où à Z colier il ne pourra pas faire ça
si je dois créer une équipe et que mon
projet j'ai rien je fais une extension
euh et que je veux de la création balle
en main sur du garde le premier que je
vais prendre c'est ISAI colir devant Rob
dildingham pour la créativité la
capacité à à bonifier le tout le monde
autourer faire des bonnes passes et
mettre tout le monde dans le rythme mais
dans cette QV si je vais aller au fit
j'ai très très peur quand la a cololière
glisse et glisse beaucoup par manque de
compatibilité par manque de de fit
justement et euh par voilà par par un
profil qui qui est pas ultra moderne
encore une fois on rediscutait je le
compare pas mal à colline Sexton alors
ça excite pas les fou comme ça mais un
Colin Sexton qui passe mieux un Colin
Seon peut-être moins athlétique et moins
défensif quand on regarde le colinon NBA
mais un colinon qui passe
mieux après c'est c'est un profil quand
même à voir parce que si un frontofice
pense que son shoot peut se développer
et il va falloir qu'il se développe
qu'il développe un pullup quoi parce que
pour pour jouer le pick and ROG il faut
il faut avoir une menace au foot si un
frontofice y croit et il a il est
tellement enfin il a il a une qualité de
passe et de création qui est assez
forte si on croit dans le shoot je pense
qu'on peut on peut on peut le tenter qui
fait remonter sa qute et c'est pour ça
que dans ma question c'était le meilleur
prospect au poste de garde parce que
justement c'était sur le côté potentiel
c'est vrai que cette draft cette QV
s'annonce assez particulière en ça donc
c'est pour ça je voulais avoir vos avis
messieurs je me rappelle aussi je sais
pas si il y a quelques temps c'était qui
qui avait fait ça c'est Darius Garland
qui s'était blessé un petit peu à la
même époque de la saison et qui avait
décidé je crois de mémoire si je dis pas
de bêtises de pas revenir est-ce que il
aurait intérêt à faire ça notre ami
colière ou pas selon vous ou est-ce que
pour lui il faut qu'il mette un dernier
coup de collier comme ça c'est fait ah
bien
ouais il fait 5 matchs avant darbilt je
crois et il fait 5 matchs avec des stade
de ouf et une efficacité de malade c'est
que genre daris Garand c'est on a on est
parti sur Chion 5 match on s'est dit
tourne à 50 % à 3 points 75 % en global
c'est c'est un monstre et il est choisi
je crois 6e 5e ou 6e juste devant Kobe
White et Jaret Culver incroyable
et colier comme il a déçu pour moi faut
qu'il rejoue faut qu'il rejoue des
matchs de conférenceut on veut le voir
face à Arizona on veut le voir face à
face ça voilà il y a Arizona dans la
Pact les voilà
mais on veut le voir face à des plus
grosses équipes et on veut le voir avec
un meilleur spacing moi j'ai envie de
voir Isaia colier entouré de bronnie
James et de Boogie elice et de voir dans
dans ce cadre làà ce qu'il peut faire
donc pour moi il a tout intérêt à à
rejouer s'il peut tu avais dit un mois
je crois juste c'est la c'est la main
c'est ça c'est un doigt qui est parti en
cacah semain ouais ouais sachant qu'il
avait déjà été blessé euh au niveau
lycéen au niveau du du genou donc euh je
ser rassemblement ouais alors du
rassemblement team
uscé donc moi je le ferai jouer si je
s'il peut jouer je le je le ferai jouer
et je pense que que la famille qui est
pas dans une démarche business et et on
vend un produit mais dans une démarche
bien-être de leur enfant éducation et
tout suivra la décision du joueur et je
pense que le joueur aime le basket donc
je le vois bien jouer Julien tu vas me
dire si tu es d'accord avec ça et si tu
peux nous parler un petit peu du de
l'homme que c'est si tu as des infos sur
ça je prends et on va enchaîner avec ça
par que moi je le connais pas je le
connais pas personnellement j'ai j'ai
mais mais millionnaire euh ce que je
voulais dire c'est que le le gars a
l'air d'avoir un fort caractère quoi
donc sur le terrain ça se voit il parl
beaucoup ils encouragent il a c'est un
volcan quoi parfois et euh et je pense
que c'est pas le gars à lâcher en fait
voilà après les un inéré de de la draft
peuvent faire que he je sais pas c'est
pour ça que je je reste prudent mais
j'ai l'impression que c'est un type qui
qui en veut et et qui le montre et qui
peut et son je crois que son sa
mentalité c'est qu'il veut emmener les
gens avec lui il le dit tout le temps
dans les interviews il veut emmener il
veut emmener l'équipe dès dès dès ses
premières interviews il dit que il va
être le leader de l'équipe il y a boogis
qui est là lui c'est pas voilà lui il
veut être un leader il savait qu'il y
avait bronnie James qui allait venir
mais il voulait s'imposer devant tout le
monde donc c'est un type comme ça voilà
c'est un type qui et ça encore une fois
c'est c'est assez bizarre son attitude
en match on peut on peut le prendre de
plusieurs façons on peut penser qu'il
est arrogant qui joue que pour sa pomme
et puis en fait je pense que c'est
plutôt un c'est plutôt un gars qui en
veut et qui veut amener tout le monde
avec lui c'est ce qui ressort un peu de
tout ce que je peux glaguer de de mon
depuis mon ordinateur et ben messieur je
je crois qu'on a fait un tour assez
complet exhaustif sur notre ami y colier
je vais y arriver euh merci beaucoup
pour tous les nos auditeurs on se
retrouve très vite en attendant prenez
soin de vous comme d'habitude nouveau
prospect on verra si c'est un Underdogs
ou si c'est un épisode Five Star vous
aurez la surprise il y aura sûrement
aussi un point bientôt sur nos French
qui sont attendus dans dans dans cette
QV et puis les big Bard sont toujours en
préparation vous inquiétez
ça va sortir aussi euh à très bientôt
tout le monde ciao ciao bye bye
[Musique]
bisous